hi I'm Alexandra Bracken doll and i'm
back with another development update
showing off m5 are closed beta build
we've been working nonstop since
releasing m4 last year and are finally
ready to share with everyone the
progress we've made most importantly
this updated snows first step as a
free-to-play game we can now handle
microtransactions in the game and player
inventories that being said there are
still many features missing they will
round out the free-to-play experience so
don't pass judgment just yet let's have
a look at what's new in the game when
you start off the game you'll
immediately see that the main menu and
ingame HUD had a facelift we've
completely redesigned and polished the
UI to tie the entire experience together
we've also improved the store and added
a whole slew of new settings also listen
out for the new main menu music that
we've had composed specifically for the
game
in the main menu you will also notice
that we've added a dozen new events and
adventure type into the game you now
have access to a few of each events I
like time trials and dissent which test
your navigation and ability to write
fast or slow style and freestyle that
tests your ability to perform tricks
all events have metal-based scores so we
look forward to seeing how many of you
can achieve a gold medal in all the
events currently available
one of the biggest features we've been
working on is a replay manager this
feature has two primary functions first
and foremost it allows you to rewind and
replay your entire game session from
different camera angles we've seen some
amazing gameplay edits from a community
on our websites share page it can't wait
to see where you come up with now that
you have more control over your shots
secondly this feature gives you the
ability to rewind gameplay if you crash
or take a wrong turn you'll be deducted
some points but at any time during game
here you can simply rewind and continue
writing from the last 10 seconds of
gameplay this definitely makes them more
unforgiving areas of the mountain more
approachable
we've added a drone to the game to help
players explore their surroundings
eventually the drone will have a few
more features attached to it like the
ability to place new spawn points but
for now it's quite helpful to find new
lines down the mountain talking about
the mountain we have over seven new
unique areas including a luxury mountain
resort and observatory a vineyard a
monument and lots of improved peace
areas to help you learn controls in a
safer environment we look forward to
seeing what interesting lines you can
come up with finally this update also
includes the initial implementation of
leveling you now earn XP from completing
events and can level up and unlock items
and free and gain credits as you
progress this only works in events right
now but we will eventually work it into
free roam as well so that's it quite a
lot of new content to check out and
enjoy we can't wait to hear everyone's
feedback on the new features so we can
continue to improve them in future
updates and don't forget if you have not
joined the early access or the closed
beta you can sign up on a website to get
your chance to play snow for free all
closed beta participants will also get
this exclusive Red Bull helmet as an
in-game reward so make sure you sign up
soon thanks for watching
you